Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es geht los mit unserer Ligatour. Heute wollen wir sprechen über die Liga in Frankreich, die Premier League in England und La Liga in Spanien mit drei Gästen, die ich euch gleich vorstelle, hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Hallo, schön, dass ihr drei hier seid. Zum einen David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 390. Hallo David. Hallo, außerdem mit dabei Uli Hebel von der Saunen und Neu. Jetzt gibt's ihn auch in Sky. Hallo Uli. Ich grüße. Und ebenfalls mit dabei Alex Truica. Ihr kennt ihn vom Tiki-Taka-Fußball-Podcast. Hallo Alex. So, wir wollen in einer Vierer-Runde über drei europäische Ligen sprechen. Und das Ganze soll es jetzt regelmäßiger geben. Das heißt, wir gehen ein bisschen weniger tief rein, aber hoffentlich wird die Schlagzahl ein bisschen höher für euch. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir probieren das mal aus. Ihr gebt uns einfach Feedback und dann schauen wir mal, wie uns allen das gefällt. Gehen wir gleich rein. Ach so, das Wortspiel Ligatour muss ich hoffentlich nicht erklären. Ansonsten googelt es an alle Typografie-Freunde da draußen. Es hat doch was mit Chirurgie zu tun. Ich meine aber das Wortspiel Typographel. So, jetzt muss man seine Wortspiele schon erklären. Es ist sehr früh. Wir beginnen mit der Ligue 1, denn da ist so einiges passiert. David, die Ligue 1 hat zum einen schon drei Spieltage hinter sich. Ich wollte dir eigentlich eine schöne Messi-Eingangsfrage stellen, aber da hat sich etwas in den Vordergrund geschoben. Beim Spiel zwischen Nizza und Olympique Marseille gestern Abend, und wir nehmen am Montag auf, kam es zu einem Spielabbruch. Während des gesamten Spiels sollen Gegenstände aus der Fankurve der Nizza-Fans auf Spieler von Olympique geworfen worden sein. Und als dann Dimitri Payet von einer Flasche getroffen wurde, feuerte er die zurück in die Zuschauer-Ränge. Es kam zu einem Platzsturm. Und hernach konnte man sehen, Marseille-Spieler wurden verletzt. Es gab Bilder auf Social Media zu sehen, bei denen man Würge-Male bei den Spielern erkennen konnte. Und es ist traurig, dass ich hier nicht übertreibe. Was war da los?
Ja, deswegen haben wir dich ja als Experten hier und nicht mich. Und war das...
So meinte ich es jetzt gar nicht, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, alles gut. Ich kann das gar nicht wissen. Ich kann diese Spiele nicht gucken. Ich muss da spekulieren. Deswegen müsst ihr mich da einordnen. Wie ist denn dann das 3 zu 3 von Real bei Levante zu bewerten, was ja ein höchst spektakuläres Spiel war? Also jeder, der die Zeit hat, dem empfehle ich noch mal so ab Minute 75 die Aufzeichnung von der Zone sich noch mal reinzuziehen und vielleicht jetzt dann zwei Minuten zu skippen, damit man nicht gespoilert wird. Aber da ging es ja auch hoch her zwischen Levante und Real.
Das war eines dieser komischen Spiele, das man nicht erklären kann. Also Bilbao gegen Barca kannst du wirklich erklären, weil das wiederkehrend ist, dass die Basken gegen Top-Teams zu Hause anrennen wie verrückt. Levante gegen Real Madrid ist eins dieser Spiele, das du nicht erklären kannst. Auch so ein typisch spanisches Spiel, wo du dir denkst, der Favorit hat alles im Griff. In der ersten Halbzeit führte Real 1-0 und Levante war wirklich chancenlos, hat körperlos agiert, in der Abwehr stimmte nichts. Und du dachtest, wenn das so weitergeht, endet es halt 3-0, 4-0, 5-0 für Real. Und zwar hoch verdient. Plötzlich wurde aus dem Nichts zur Halbzeit irgendwo ein Hebel umgesetzt, umgelegt. Und Levante schoss aus dem Nichts ein, zwei Tore und hatte dann plötzlich Oberwasser. Und du wusstest nicht, woher das kommt. Hat natürlich der Trainer von Levante die richtigen Worte gefunden. Oder hat sich Real gedacht, das wird locker. Hier der Gegner ist so schwach, wir können das auch easy im dritten Gang runterspielen. Wahrscheinlich stimmt beides und dann kommt eins zum anderen. Aber es war nicht vorhersehbar, dass das Spiel so eskaliert. Ja, völlig verrückte Partie, wilde Partie. Und wie das im Fußball halt dann so ist, manchmal schaukelt es sich hoch. Fans im Stadion, glaube ich in Spanien, tun da noch mal ein bisschen was ihr Übriges, weil die Spanier das ja überhaupt nicht mehr gewohnt sind. Also ja, es war ein absolut wildes, unerklärliches Spiel.
Also Levante hat das gedreht bis zur 57. Minute. Vinicius Junior dann ausgeglichen, der 73. in der 79. erneute Führung für Levante. In der 85. Ausgleich von Vinicius durch ein entweder Geniestreich oder schiefgegangene Reingabe, so oder so, was einfach ein wunderschöner Treffer. Und dann natürlich musste da noch was passieren. In der 87. Minute muss Aitor Fernandes einen Ball mit der Hand gegen Vinicius kurz hinter der Mittellinie klären. Sie sieht dafür die rote Karte. Ein Feldspieler muss zwischen die Pfosten gehen, weil Levante schon fünfmal gewechselt hat. Real schafft es aber nicht. Ich glaube, die haben kein einziges Mal mehr aufs Tor geschossen in dieser Phase. Hat mich wundert, dass da nicht einer einfach mal abgezogen hat. Aber es war hochdramatisch mit sechs, sieben Minuten Nachspielzeit wirklich sehr schön, noch mal nachzusehen. Hab ich gestern Nacht auch gemacht.
Das war übrigens auch ein typisches Levantespiel, wenn die gegen die großen spielen. Ein bisschen ähnlich wie bei Athletic Bilbao. Die sind einfach wirklich noch mal motivierter. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die nur sie kennen. Also wenn Levante gegen, sagen wir, Rayo Valle Cano, Ossasuna oder Retafe spielt, brauchst du dir diese Spiele gar nicht ansehen. Du kannst vorab mit einer 70%igen Wahrscheinlichkeit 0-0 oder 1-1 prognostizieren. Und sobald sie aber gegen Real Barca und Athletico spielen, sind sie unberechenbar. Beispiel nicht nur dieses 3 zu 3 jetzt, also gestern. Letzte Saison gegen Barcelona auch ein 3 zu 3 zu Hause. Da lagen sie sogar 0 zu 2 hinten, waren eigentlich auch chancenlos. Im Wandermetropolitano bei Athletico hat Levante 2-0 gewonnen. Und bei Real Madrid, im Di Stefano, hat Levante 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Also absolut verrückte Ergebnisse für die Mannschaft, die eigentlich eine graue Maus ist und die nie besser als Platz 9 oder Platz 12 in Spanien ist. Aber gegen die großen drei sind sie aus irgendwelchen Gründen immer top motiviert und spielen ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste, wenn man so will. Also nichts zu verlieren und stürmen drauf los und überraschen die Großen immer wieder.
Na ja, Augsburg gewinnt ja auch hin und wieder gegen den BVB. Das ist nicht so komplett unbekannt und ist ansonsten dann doch manchmal grauer als grau, möchte man fast schon sagen. Wir sind schon am Ende angelangt. Gibt es noch eine Mannschaft oder etwas, was du uns noch erklären wirst, was jetzt in den ersten zwei Spieltagen völlig überraschend war? Oder läuft La Liga halt einfach so los und man muss dann in ein paar Spieltagen noch mal genauer drauf gucken?
Tatsächlich gibt es bisher aus meiner Sicht nichts Überraschendes. Die Top 3, gut, zwei Spiele gespielt, nicht mal alle Partien absolviert, aber die Top 3 sind wie letztes Jahr, Atletico, Real Barca, sogar in der identischen Reihenfolge. Obwohl, zwei Patzer es schon gab, von Real und Barca, beide nur unentschieden, das kommt so ein bisschen vielleicht überraschend für den einen oder anderen, aber gänzlich ja auch nicht, wenn man ehrlich ist, weil beide Vereine einfach jetzt seit, ich würde sogar sagen, drei Jahren nicht mehr das allerhöchste europäische Niveau haben. Sprich, die werden immer wieder, vor allem in Auswärtsspielen, Punkte lassen. Und Atletico macht Atletico-Dinge. Ein 2-1, ein Dusel 2-1 bei Celta und jetzt ein sehr, sehr langweiliges 1-0 gegen Elche, wo gefühlt wirklich gar nichts passiert ist, außer dem Siegtuor von Atletico. Das war schön, aber ansonsten typisches Atletico-Spiel.
Gut, Business as Usual in Spanien, Business as Unusual hier im Rasenfunk. Ein neues Format. Ich habe komplett den Überblick verloren, bei wie viel Minuten Laufzeit wir jetzt sind. Denn wir hatten zwischendurch technische Probleme. Wenn ihr nichts davon gehört habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann hat nicht nur Uli 3-mal wirklich perfekt dieselbe Antwort gegeben, sondern wir haben auch sonstige technische Probleme noch irgendwie eliminiert bekommen. Ich danke euch beiden ganz, ganz herzlich und stellvertretend auch noch mal, David. Einmal Uli Hebel von Dazorn und Sky. Add Uli Hebel auf Twitter. Danke dir, Uli, dass du mit dabei warst bei dieser Premiere. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an Alex Truica. Man kann ihn hören im Tikitaka-Podcast. Unter anderem, man kann ihn lesen bei barcawelt.de. Man kann ihm auf Twitter folgen. Da heißt er, add Alex Truica. Alles maximal einfach. Danke dir, Alex, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr gerne.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Wenn alles nach Plan verläuft, dann werden wir in der nächsten Woche hier über die zweite Bundesliga der Männer sprechen. Und dann gucken wir mal, in welcher Taktung diese Ligatur hier dann kommen wird und wie wir das genau gestalten. Gebt uns gerne Feedback. Auf mitmachen.rasen.de ist dafür die Gelegenheit. Freue mich auf den nächsten Rasen vom Kurzpass. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, passt auf euch auf, bis bald, ciao!